[Music]
I'll keep the Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV
and Movie Channel live with our strike
Survival Guide we're here to help you
get through these strikes with telling
you what entertainment you should be
watching and we're here with everybody
say hello everybody hello everybody
alcoholic beverage
right yeah this is vodka sugar covering
from alcoholic beverage yeah
he's got some sort of cookbook
the problem with that massive bottle one
second anyway
[Music]
Mr mama was a new member just before we
came on live by the way so thank you
very much for becoming a member of the
team
you're an absolute legendary
that intro did not play for me I saw two
seconds of it and then we were back but
I've just seen it on the replay it
worked fine but it's all good
foreign
I was gonna say I was gonna say Harris
your bottle is the reason there are so
many earthquakes in America
this thing down and just goes off you
know that's right yeah if ever you drive
towards San Andreas just leave the
[__] bottle all right because it will
be the big one all right
so we'll tell you how this is going to
work then guys so we are going to pick
the top 10 shows that you should watch
during strikes to keep you through and
keep you entertained we have two picks
each we're gonna make up our top eight
and then we have one more pick each
which we're then going to argue over to
decide the top ten we're then going to
talk a little bit about the strike
because stormy has got something he
wants to say damn it and then we might
talk a little bit about AI in movies
because I went to see
um uh the Mission Impossible movie today
I really really enjoyed it Gary hey boys
and Davey B is in the house as well
um first of all let's let's throw out
there if we if we go that way round
so it'll be Matt stormy Harris Smith
with your first picks so we we haven't
gone definitely
um sci-fi here either we've we've had a
few other obviously we're sci-fi fans so
it might be a bit sci-fi heavy but we're
just going with I've picked two shows
that I genuinely genuinely want to sit
and watch so
Matthew
so we're doing both shows at the same
time and we'll build it up and we'll go
around we'll go around tonight well my
first show that I was going to pick it
was a toss-up between two
um I've decided to go for breaking bad
because I think it's one of the best
honestly the best shows you can binge if
you've never seen it there are people
who have never seen it yep watch it my
boss had only if you've never seen that
I watched the first three seasons I got
so bored I stopped
I'll go about halfway through the second
one oh mate no my boss hadn't seen that
I told I told him like literally like
one of the first weeks I decided this
new job he needs to watch it and then he
he watched it the whole lot within about
a month
I need to take the Breaking Bad Tour you
know I live in in Southern New Mexico
now in his film just right up the road
so I've really got to go take the
Breaking Bad to a friend of mine's
taking it she's oh you gotta go take it
the woman who owns Walt's house doesn't
she like hate people like being outside
the house probably I would I'm sure
thrown on a roof right yeah
why would you do that though why would
you go if somebody says like we're going
to film a TV show here yeah of course
nobody will see that or nobody will find
out where I live it's just stupid why
would you do that
I want to make people just go on a
Friday night just sling a pizza up there
just you know a drive by a drive-by
Pizza in you know you never go hungry
just open the front door and wait
so yeah my first pick is Breaking Bad
just because it's one of one of if not
the greatest TV show
to come out in the last like 20 years
I think it's just the perfect TV show
you need to carry on watching it because
it gets way better after season three
it's one of those slow Burns Harris will
look I think I've seen it he loves a
slow burner I I really like slow Burns
and Breaking Bad is the epitome of Slow
Burn
it is I mean because it literally Burns
right up until the end and then the last
episode is brilliant
plus episode
not quite it's only five seasons yeah I
only have to wait through four and three
quarters of a season for it to get good
well that's unless you go Better Call
Saul then you got an extra couple
is Good from season one yes
uh that is the one thing the only reason
I haven't watched that is because I
didn't watch Breaking Bad so do I
actually need to watch Breaking Bad to
enjoy Better Call Saul
because
[Music]
really but you'd appreciate it more if
you watched Breaking Bad first yeah
yeah because there are characters in it
who appear in Breaking Bad that you
otherwise you'll just think they're just
random characters but you'll appreciate
it more watch watch Breaking Bad first
definitely right well unfortunately
because this is a top ten I have to so I
don't have a choice so um this is this
these are literally the shows I'm going
to be watching for the next several
months so there we go Breaking Bad is in
the top 10 Davey B is just thrown in the
top ten so we let's whip through quickly
while we're waiting
um Babylon 5 DS9 X-Files Game of Thrones
lost the wire wire is a great show
Walking Dead nah Stillman you hate
Walking Dead don't you I mean I I think
you should just swear at Dave no I like
walking dead keep kidding I don't like
walking dead
I like my engine uh Father Ted West
Winger Stargate Atlantis oh that was the
one rule we did say for this top ten no
Stargate
otherwise
yeah we'd all just picked stargations
funnily enough you have to watch
Stargate Atlantis again funnily enough
in my top picks Doctor Who isn't even in
there oh
man I'm a massive Doctor Who look look
I've got baby tenants like I've touched
his penis yeah
I've just touched David's 10 inch yeah
it's amazing how quickly this show goes
right to the dick doesn't it it's just
I mean I wish we didn't go straight to
the dick pretty much at least three
times in every video but we do so
it's mostly storm is Fault hey story
what is your first choice sir okay so I
I went and picked three per streaming
service and then I'm trying to narrow it
down for the first pick
in case the
this is based on in case the strike goes
on for a long time you know something
that can really bog you down and take
you months to get through so so that's
my criteria and so the the thing I think
uh my first choice is going to be
X-Files lots of seasons of X-Files there
were 20 some episodes per season
and it really covered a lot of uh horror
and sci-fi and it really
there hasn't been a show like it since
you know and I'm not really sure if
there ever will be something that was so
uh culturally impactful as X-Files so my
first one is definitely X-Files from the
beginning to the end and throw in the
movies
I'm
seeing parallels with French
because Fringe for me was like
obviously I I watch French first now I'm
watching The X-Files it reminds me a
little bit of of Fringe but obviously
it's all the way around Fringe would
have reminded me of X-Files had I
watched it
yeah
X-Files on Hulu
yeah yeah
well we get it we get we don't really
have Hulu oh that's right
the BBC really missed a trick with
giving Doctor Who to Disney they could
have give it to Hulu doctor Hulu
[Laughter]
doctor Hulu
um that would have been very cool
interest in things
um I just want to assume they would like
but then no one in the UK would have
watched it
yeah a Hawaiian a Hawaiian doctor Doctor
Who
that the first season in particular The
X-Files changed television
you know yeah some movies have come
along that everybody copies it from then
on and X-Files is one of those shows
that everybody just everybody tried to
copy it and I don't think right since
yeah it was really unique
hey Brett
Wilcox is in the house
you know in terms of like X-Files and
culture I mean there was this thing
called the Scully effect
where a lot of girls uh in their
formative years looked up to her
character and went into uh stamp careers
you know the sciences and because you
know they saw a positive role model
yeah
that had better sense than the guy
more sensible more sense of life in the
sky it's definitely a UFO it's a plain
older
smudge on your contacts well it's to the
point that even when she was in
kidnapped by aliens you're still going
maybe it's a play molder because they're
literally probing you now
sexual assault or something I don't know
kind of like Matt was doing with uh
Doctor Who David Taylor yeah
sorry David
what she did actually it did it did
start to get a little bit ridiculous at
one point they said
Scully you've seen quite a lot at some
point open your mind a bit and I mean
she did like it took like eight like
eight seasons or something
um oh so she's always going so I'm only
on the first season she's always going
to be the cynical one no it switches and
then we get to the movies he becomes
really cynical and she's the one that's
trying to support him and I go let's
let's believe it
um because she obviously sees it but um
I just thought she was very very pretty
and I don't care and beyond that so
and she wins
um but yeah I put I put um I did not
know what your list was before we
started obviously but um she is on the
thumbnail because I can do one
X-Files first particularly the first
season
Harris what is your first choice here
well
I'm going to punch you in the dick by
the way all right so there's this other
kind of fantasy version of Futurama that
is called I'm getting I I do love that
show though
honorable mention there uh but it is an
animated show I wish I can watching now
shall I the what so I write Rick and
Morty now oh but it's not even sci-fi
well I'm not sci-fi there's steampunk
elements and then sci-fi ask elements
but avatar The Last Airbender I think is
one of the best series ever made and
it's three seasons just greatness 20
minutes an episode
pop that sucker on just enjoy it the
last episode's an hour and a half like
the best TV movie ever done
it's so damn good
Mark Hamill is firelord ozai Isaac could
just go on yeah yeah I just went voices
Mark I'm only loads of voices
particularly in the like 90s I know he
was in like the DC stuff I didn't know
it was in Avatar he's the main villain
yeah I've never watched that I was
always a digimon kid so so I saw I was
watching Tick Tock and there was this
little kid
uh I don't know where he was
he was on this uh like uh boardwalk and
is Right close to the ocean and he's
doing all these you know moves you know
and then right when he does this the
waves just that's cool
he's just under the Boardwalk down by
the sea
with his baby
um
it's kind of musical you're just
preparing yourself for that Star Trek
musical yeah I'm hoping
are we going to get a buff yes Style
Star Trek movie or show yeah we're gonna
get a musical
[Applause]
Star Trek yeah
on it go watch my video on it I've
dropped it today it's a lot of fun and
I'm I'm a firm supporter in them doing
this Star Trek musical I think it's a
great idea do you sing throughout the uh
video I was tempted to at the end I was
gonna go no longer Prosper but I decided
not to
um because
I try to be really positive in the video
but if my God it's a stupid idea
um but I'm with you on avatar The Last
Airbender mate what do you think the
chances of the Netflix series that cost
them five million dollars an episode
what do you think the chance of that
being any good
oh the average of The Last Airbender
live action yep I am optimistic and
terrified all at once
I like that they planned everything out
and and did that aspect of it with the
creators that made the original show but
then they left for a creative
differences so
I don't know
we're we're gonna see how it happens and
I'm hoping for the best uh but but
they've included a lot of characters
that are like in later seasons of avatar
The Last Airbender and
put them in the first season a lot like
Kyoshi is going to be there a lot the
the Earth goddess and they're not
goddess but the Earth Avatar uh and
she's like in two episodes really very
memorable two episodes but now she's
gonna be that like consistent figure
that he goes back to like ask advice to
huh so we'll see we'll see
OG is always there though I own it it's
on Paramount plus it's on everything
it's always there okay well power my
plus is brilliant at the moment I am
that that's basically all I'm watching
um I watched that werewolf thing so
Michelle Kelly just because I love say
Michelle Galla but I actually quite
liked it I'm watching rabbit hole at the
moment with um with uh Keith Sutherland
and that's really really good and I
really want to watch the um there's like
a cop show with Morgan Freeman and
it's like a military show
um I mean I forgot the name but I'm
roots in the advert's fat I can't wait
what really I can really watch it anyway
my first choice
I want to wind back a little bit what uh
David B said the X-Files like a spin off
the show Night Stalker Cole Shack The
Night Stalker with Darren McGavin I'm
thinking wise
and I I remember I remember when that
came out what a great show that was you
know there was tried they tried to do a
remake a few years back and the Remake
was absolutely horrible
but uh
Miguel really did a great job you know
in telling that story
and yeah he was a reporter running
around but you know it was like the
other side of the FBI kind of destroy it
was just like monster of the weekend I
think but the writing was really well
done really well done and
hats off to David B for bringing that up
but yeah I watched that about 20 years
after it was made because I was four and
um I was minus four sorry my parents had
just had my big brother at that point
but um lioness is yeah it's called
lionesses I'm really looking forward to
that I can't believe this is of the
England women's football team that I'm
very excited about but um that's what
made me keep thinking I must watch that
anyway my first pick is we've already
mentioned it is The Fringe uh or just
Fringe
um back Once Upon a Time
when JJ Abrams was actually quite good
at his job before he ruined all of our
beloved franchises all of them
um yeah The Fringe was just a brilliant
series even though that Joshua Jackson
in it who was an actor I hate
hate him so much
um he played Peter Bishop it's just it
just looks like a freaking idiot but he
grew a bit of a beard and actually made
it made him look less of an idiot so I I
really love that
um I loved Walter though in it the the I
think his name was John Noble after
friend he was in everything for a bit
the boys
and he was in the boys yeah he's like
um
Billy Bush's Dad I think yeah yeah he's
in that he's just brilliant accent he's
in Return of the King by the way
yeah the guy who played Jennifer
yes yeah exactly he's just very bad
eating habits
about him yeah but back in 2008 you know
JJ Abrams was actually able to make some
pretty good TV he made this it was I I
100 agree with you the like the format
was very X-Files he
first episode though blew me a freaking
way I bought the like the airplane thing
and the oh it was open episode is
fantastic but the main reason why I've
picked it is I've not watched this
series since it came out I watched it
when it was out
and I've not watched it since so that's
that was 2008 it came out and I've not
watched it since
so you know I watched it in about 10
years I think yeah exactly so I'm
thinking
I'm ready for a bit of
um Fringe once again so that's why it's
online
um never hand JJ Abrams an existing IP
no he's he's quite good when he does his
own stuff he's not so good when he tries
to and also don't let him finish his own
product projects let somebody else come
in there and finish for him you know the
only problem with fringe is the last
season that's good the last season did
sort of they didn't quite it was a bit
like lost wasn't it I think they didn't
they painted themselves it was just a
complete U-turn it wasn't just it wasn't
anything like season what how many
seasons were there five five seasons
yeah yeah so season five wasn't the same
as season four it was a complete like
narrative shift everything was
completely different it was just weird
also it was all right but
any of you guys watch Abrams is uh alias
not all the way through I did
but I didn't I never really quite got
into that
I watched the like the first couple
seasons and then it kind of
change channels or time slots or and
then or something else came on or I
don't know I think I watched the first
season but I never quite got into it
that's the one with them uh uh Ben
Affleck's wife Jennifer Jennifer
Sanders Jennifer Sanders no that's him
that's something else that's comedian
um but yeah she was in it when she but
yeah
I never I never loved it
but um I watched that um the one with
the I don't know anyway moving on so
that was my first choice anyway Fringe
so we got four
that's Four Seasons we've all got to
watch so Matthew what is your second
definite choice for the top ten
a definite second choice
um would it would have been Fringe but
you'd already picked it
so I'm thinking what TV shows do I tend
to have on rotation
and my second choice is going to be
heroes
oh okay because I loved I loved the rest
no all of them all the second season the
second season I um I absolutely hate and
I do tend to skip quite a lot of
episodes in season two yeah season three
and four were really good
I never watched Heroes I've always meant
to and I just never have
I
love the evil people
um Peter's dad was
evil he was great liked him I was
rooting for the evil guy the bad guy
and then at the end of season four they
made Sila good and I hated it but
whatever
it got canceled after that so I just
imagined he then turned evil again
it's one of them shows that was a victim
to uh the writers Strike Back In 2008.
that's why 2000 I think this point the
second season was wank
I think it was a victim of its own
success as well the first season was
just ridiculously popular and the second
season was never gonna live up to
expectations it was like everybody was
like I'm gonna go save the cheerleader
oh yeah yeah
absolutely save the world yeah and I was
like it was just ridiculous nobody
expected that show to be anything like
that popular and there was nowhere for
it to go or something they're like oh
[__] we're collecting this
I don't know there was plenty of places
for it to go so the second season was it
just got caught short they they
literally got given half the
um episodes that they were given for the
first season and subsequently third and
fourth
there were plenty there was plenty of
story to have because for season three
and four was great it was just I think a
victim of the writer strike and
you can tell
you can tell Xena Warrior Princess
actually I was just thinking about that
I haven't thought about Xena in a long
time I like some Xena yeah
I see your Instagram I saw her in I was
watching
um oh that spy show with Michael Weston
my name is Michael Weston I'm a spy
what's that I've been I've watched all
of it at the moment and I can't remember
the name uh Burn Notice she was in Burn
Notices
gorgeous she was also uh in X-Files also
in Battlestar Galactica
he had prominent roles in all of those
not just uh guest slots she had a really
good guest Garden Agents of Shield see
her boobs and spots is there a film
called Burn Notice
possibly maybe the series is great
anyway
I don't know if I'm remembering it right
but I've seen something and I'm sure it
was called Burn Notice and there's a guy
who gets strapped to a car with a bomb
is that the same thing you're thinking
of
this was a USA Network here is a hero
show is about a spy that had been
uh more or less just let go and he was
uh on his own and he was just
running around
doing stuff that was kind of spyish and
he always talked you know he had like
kind of broke the uh
uh kind of the fourth pain talking to
the audience of what all is going on in
terms of uh excuse me in terms of
spycraft yeah oh loads of loads of
brilliant tips I had to get away with
murderous and things if you actually
like take notes really good
um like evasion techniques and all sorts
but that's great sure if that's my go-to
background show when I'm working and I
don't really wanna concentrate on it and
it's my that's my go-to show at the
moment when I'm working
um oh I'm sorry go ahead I've just done
a quick Google search and I can't I
can't find I can't see it under Burn
Notice this might be under some
completely different yeah it also had a
Bruce Campbell as a co-star and that's
one of the reasons why I love it because
I just love Bruce Campbell give me some
sugar baby come on stormy give me some
sugar
but the great Bruce Campbell yeah can't
argue that
um all right where are we at where are
we at where are we at uh so yes it's
Heroes the first season none of the rest
because the rest were rubbish first
I'm gonna put all of them in there even
the second season because you need the
second season for the third and fourth
to make sense do we have to put in the
reboot
reborn did not happen
not reborn because it was [__]
my problem with Heroes Reborn right
right I'm gonna go into this now right
so Heroes Reborn okay Claire Danette she
is the cheerleader who can regenerate
and it was already established during
the show that when the
um eclipse happened you will lose your
powers that was established that's
absolutely fine but when the eclipse
ends you get your powers back
Now cast your minds back to season one
when Claire Bennett had the things that
the shivs shoved in her head and she
died
when that was pulled out she then
regenerated so effectively when that was
in her head her powers weren't working
in Heroes Reborn the reason why she's
not in the show is because she died
during childbirth because there was an
eclipse at the time
which doesn't make sense because even if
she did die during an eclipse when the
eclipse ended she would have come back
to life
because it happened before
I care I [__] care
I don't think the problems with that
sure there's other much bigger but no I
know I know he could even I hate it when
established Cannon gets well either just
completely ignored for the story or
forgotten about or in this case that
couldn't get
I want to say her name is Patisserie
Hayden Panettiere
Hayden Patisserie is um I can't say that
um and if they couldn't get her in it
because she was married to she married
to like
a tennis player or something she's
married somebody really famous
I don't know anyway I don't care but
they couldn't get her in it so they just
made up some nonsense reason why she
wasn't in it anyway stormy what's what's
he could have just ignored it just
ignored it on holiday for that week they
didn't have Peter in it they didn't have
Siler in it and I know Zachary Quinto
was like big during like Star Trek time
during that time that's why he wouldn't
have done it but Milo Venta Melody where
the hell the hell Peter's name is in
real life was doing [__] all and he
could have been in it
even Nathan was in it and everyone hates
Nathan
yeah everyone hated that show
the first season of Heroes was excellent
and I've got to watch this now but not
reborn not reborn I don't have to watch
reborn
reborn didn't happen
stormy number six on our list is so uh
going for longevity in case the strike
continues for a very long time I'm going
to get a little bit vintage on you guys
and I'm going to recommend not the not
the movie
not the failed attempt of a remake but
I'm going back to the OG here I'm going
to Dark Shadows
I get to watch it
1230 episodes of Jonathan freed being a
vampire
1225 episodes
230. what are you talking about
you said 235 or 1235
1230 I think according to IMDb
I'm going hiking
um when this goes ticks through nine
years this right to strike I'll be maybe
just about finished watching Doctor
right so why should we watch Dark
Shadows other than 1200 episodes I think
30 minutes at least they're not an hour
are they I think they're three million
episodes
right so why should we watch Dark
Shadows because we never really got it
here in the UK so I've never seen it
you've never okay so um I think here
really you you want to start watch so
I'll I'll help you out here you want to
start watching it when Jonathan freed
first appears
because Dark Shadows was impossible 100
episode
it was a show about this um fancy New
England family the Collins's and it was
your standard kind of darkish
uh Dark fan not really dark fantasy it's
just kind of darkish morose depressive
soap opera back in the 70s
we're 60s and 70s and um
sorry just saw that comment and so it
was going to get it was going to get
canceled so Dan Curtis the producer said
well [__] let's just do whatever we want
to do then right and just ride out the
rest of the contract
so let's say oh there's this ancestor of
the Collins family called you know
Barnabas Collins let's make him a
vampire then Willie Lomas he's the
gardener let's throw him out there in
the back in the back lot and open up the
coffin and then turns out there's a
vampire in there and it was so popular
with everybody that it got renewed
miraculously for many years to come it
became this it became the show that
college students went home back to their
dorms to watch it was extremely popular
like the whole demon position that was
not her kind of thing but she loved it
she loved it
so dark shadows
but with like Dracula's yeah oh I was
there was werewolves there were ghosts
it started out as just like you know
kind of a depressive
um New England kind of uh vibe that was
getting canceled and then the producer
said well let's just throw in Vampires
because what do we got to lose let's
just go out with him and then it became
popular every show should do that yeah
I'm looking at the wiki for this show
and it says it come out in 66. yeah and
the last episode was in 71 how did they
have so many episodes in between that's
like what five five years
oh see they just never stopped
you know they would they would shoot
like a uh five episodes a week
so it's literally like a soap opera it
was unlike every night it was a soap
opera it was a soap opera new production
every day just like Guiding Light or As
the World Turns or any of those
it was just another soap opera but this
yeah it's five five episodes a week that
that checks out sorry to change Jericho
was brilliant when I was watching the
boys I'm like where the hell do I know
this guy from right who is this guy I
know him from something [__] Jericho
anyway Jericho yeah Lee Wilcox is right
it was the EastEnders of sci-fi
which I think they should do I mean
EastEnders would be so much more
interesting is this like when somebody
has an affair with somebody else then
the Vampire comes in and eats them both
so much better
um so we need to we need to we need to
we need a Sci-Fi
like soap opera again I mean because
they could just do mental [__] with it I
mean
I don't know man Coronation Street with
werewolves once a month everybody just
gets eaten
um it'd be great
um right so dark shadows um do I have to
watch the movie with Johnny deppman no
that's we're gonna ask and you don't
have to watch the uh miniseries
that had
Alex what's his name as Barnabas he was
in he he played um
uh Paul of trades in the Sci-Fi
mini-series Dune something
I'll have that name up in a second
I said I love this I didn't watch
Jericho at first because I thought it
was a Bible Bastion and it really wasn't
yeah it really really wasn't Al Newman
Alec Newman played Barnabas ignore that
too okay right when we got Dark Shadows
so number seven on the list Harris is up
to you lucky number seven what we going
for well
who else I I might say
this is
possibly my favorite series ever
possibly possibly I I you know it
changes every day but I it's the one I
go back to and like if I have to put
something in that slot I typically put
this one I just finished
and it just finished it's SQL series
Mayans FX or Mayans MC on FX
but Sons of Anarchy I think those those
eight seasons or seven seasons of just
near perfectness it reinvents itself
like two or three times and each time it
just totally changes what it is and
continues it and in all of its Glory
it's perfect it's terrifying it's awful
it's great it's Sons of Anarchy I love
it
if you were to compare you've seen
Walking Dead haven't you yeah
Sons of Anarchy or Walking Dead which
one is better oh Sons of Anarchy all day
like I I think Walking Dead has a better
first season I think the first season
The Walking Dead is one of the best
first seasons of Television maybe ever
David's happy down here the series
finale from Mayans was this past
Thursday and I was just devastated for
like two hours after it made me watch
something that y'all are gonna be very
happy that I started watching but I'm
saving that for just a little bit
okay you know so so my uh my favorite
character was actually a character that
was in both of those series link Lincoln
Park Lincoln Potter oh
I don't want to say anything because
David's in here but the way Lincoln
Potter's story ends in Mayans is great
it's great yep now one thing
one thing is just Ray McKinnon the actor
that plays link
he had he he has an Oscar that hardly
anybody knows about
I think he produced wrote and produced
this uh one little short movie
called the accountant
not the one with
yeah
wasn't that
the account it was it was he wrote it it
was only just it was uh he he played
McKinnon plays an accountant that I
don't want to give away the uh
I don't want to give away the plot of
what he's doing but it was an excellent
short little movie about a half hour I
think it was and who won an Oscar
best short film
so he is actually an awesome winner and
hardly anybody knows it so I'm just you
know showing love for uh Ray McKinnon
here
soon Savannah King and I I am definitely
gonna sit and watch it thank you because
I've got to because I've agreed I'm
gonna watch all 10 episodes but um Peggy
from
um married to Children's in it so I you
admit that to be honest you could have
just gone Peggy's in it and I'll go oh
what's up
just come for that some good movies big
movie startups because they've got big
parts and stuff and I'm like who the
bloody hell is this guy and I have to go
back and I was in Sons of Anarchy I
can't even remember the guy's name is it
I don't I'm probably misquoting the band
but uh it's not Metallica but one of
some big heavy metal singers in like the
last two seasons too and he plays like
some like uh white power kind of like
background dude that's bad and stuff but
he plays excellently and it just the
people they bring in are great so good
um or you could have just said uh Leela
plays in it and now it would have been
fun
did you guys watch Millennium well it
came out yes oh my God yes oh um thingy
from Aliens and that and
um
didn't have enough Focus for me I think
that was the problem with it it never
quite never quite it was too much
mystery not in a focus and people just
didn't really know what they were
watching
yeah very cerebral but maybe the
um people didn't get it so right second
series on my list right is a bit left
field all right my reasons
um and it's basically because I didn't
watch it so I've never seen it right
um it's got a very pretty lady in it
who's naked for most of the series and I
kind of want to see that
um because I'm a boy how can you make a
recommendation on something you've not
seen because I'm I'm not recommending it
I'm saying this is these are the series
I want to binge
I always wanted to watch it but I I
never got a chance to see it so I really
want to watch Homeland all right so I am
going to binge it so I am saying that
this is these are my two choices because
I'm desperate to watch it Marina
um
[Music]
she's in Homer and she's brilliant and
we got to see so much of her in it and
then they both sort of giggle I was like
why are they giggling and then I asked
my wife and she's like yeah she's naked
for most now
I think the first time we see her she's
got her boobs but anyway I don't care I
want to say anyway I'm taking it that's
not why I want to watch it I actually I
love I love clay he's excellent Homeland
is excellent is yeah it really it also
one thing I liked about it has nothing
to do with terrorism or whatever but it
really started to treat uh his very
first television shows that really
started to treat mental illness
respect
I think there was so much going on and I
said I I know what was I sort of know
what was happening my wife actually have
seen it so I do know bits and mobs about
why and that just inspired me even more
than I just really want to watch it
um and I love Claire Danes but my main
reasons wanted to watch it I joke about
Andrea's boobs
um but
um I've seen Deadpool so obviously
um but it's Damian Lewis I think Damian
Lewis is one of the is the most
underrated just brilliant actors we've
had for years he did that Stephen King
film that was with the eight with the
giant alien thing
was just brilliant
um
um yeah it's just I just desperately
want to watch it I can't believe I've
never have seen it
so I'm gonna
what's the other show we're seeing is is
it billionaires or uh-huh these are
billions yeah billions of numbers
um but yeah I'm gonna watch Homeland so
that is on my list 2011. it was on
Showtime
also Mandy Mandy Patinkin is in it yeah
um who's another actor actually it's
inconceivable but I've never seen in
this series it's conceivable damn it
um but he's brilliant and he actually I
believe he left CSI not CSI he left
Criminal Minds to do this show so for me
that also just says It's gotta be a good
show so it's you know it's it's I don't
want to piss off the Criminal Minds fans
but Homeland is really dark really
gritty it was really timely in
concerning you know the
uh 911 and
the war in Iraq and Afghanistan just and
and he has such great lines he has such
a great character I mean he really was
able I mean I think Showtime gave him
the freedom to do exactly what he that
part needed to do and now it was no way
in hell that was whenever we're going to
make it to uh network television what
was the last good like Showtime show
because they used to just come out with
stuff just as much like HBO that was
okay
it's isn't it still a highest rated show
like I think it is I mean it's just it
left for sci-fi and it's
it's yeah
it's the highest opening we promised we
weren't going to mention Stargate but
um it's yeah it's oh we never promise we
wouldn't mention it
we're just not put it on a list
but yeah amazing amazing show right we
gotta we've got our top eight now we've
got to pick up our last two but there's
only we've got four of us and there's
only two spaces so there's gonna be some
argument
um I suspect Harris is going to come up
with something just a little easier to
dismiss
actually you picked a great show so
that's cool so right Matthew what is
your first wild card what is your first
pick choice to try to argue with your
way into this
well the my third one I was going to
pick as as my first but
I opted for Breaking Bad instead and
most of my third is is Better Call Saul
on the on the very basis that you need
to watch Breaking Bad first
okay that's why I didn't make it my
number one
because I do think
um Better Call Saul is better
than Breaking Bad even though Breaking
Bad is the perfect TV show for me
medical saw was better
Sopranos oh why didn't they pick The
Sopranos so much better than Breaking
Bad
ah The Sopranos
scrap this list just watch The Sopranos
um it's a good show though um but it's
not on this but yeah okay better call
Sir
um I love nobody nobody who's my
favorite film last year I thought it was
just the the wording Kirk is just
fantastic and that's why I desperately
need it
2021 wasn't it
[Laughter]
[Music]
um but anyway okay still have a rocket
into your house
all right so this
is 20 number threes but I'm gonna go
um
there's several reasons why I'm going
for this title one is there's a lot of
episodes for us to watch uh it was
really good really good acting uh it had
a decent start but I thought unlike a
lot of series finales it was really
really really strong
especially the season finale I mean it
was I've never seen something so
emotional and so perfectly wrapping up
everything and that is Supernatural
okay that is on my list to watch because
I mean you know
you know the two brothers they go
through thick and thin then I don't want
to if someone hasn't seen it
I don't want to spoil it but there's an
event at the very end and how they're
two lives diverge it just I was just
really I was I was not crying [__] you
guys I was not crying it was really
really well done so yeah like a baby
uh the guy that played Satan in it is
one of my favorite actors who plays
Badger and fast um in Firefly yeah he's
doing all sorts and I just love it for
Galactica yeah I've never watched or I
haven't watched all of Supernatural
um I started to watch it got my mind
distracted by other things so that is
100 on my list you might have had a very
good shout there sir four to make the
top 10. I
yeah I'm also I've I had a thought I've
got a uh I've got an uncle that is a
hardcore bible thumper he's very much
into eschatology into the world [__] so
I'm trying to get him to watch it
I think he would enjoy it I mean fallen
angels and demons and he he attended I
think this virtual uh prophecy
conference it's about the end times and
they actually played a clip and I think
that gave me a little bit more
ammunition to or a little bit more
emphasis go watch this you know because
I think Dean is the thing that he
rattled back to me was uh well he said
one of the characters said well I didn't
even know Satan was dating
you know so
um I I think for serious horror serious
sci-fi guys and and maybe the
eschatology crowd would be something
that they could watch and and in
literally you know enjoy
this is the CW It's Supernatural what
channel yeah it was a CW Show yeah let's
see what do we think they did well well
you're gonna say sorry Harris before
I said I said can I have Can I submit a
fourth
no I'm just gonna say a supernatural
who's currently on Netflix unless you
unless we we will have to maybe argue at
the end we'll go back around again if
there's any other arguments we can have
as many as we left because I can't
believe I didn't say this one no I'm a
little bit but we can't believe it
either and we're so disappointed I can't
believe Paris what's your third pick
well just because Matt just said talk
about four I'm gonna go ahead and cheat
and and put four in here real quick uh
Mayans
and legends
fourth third one put your third one in
and then um
sequel shows
of the ones I said earlier
uh no but realistically I would say go
watch the sequel shows watch Mayans
watch Legend of Korra but the one I'm
choosing just to make you all proud
because I'm I'm I think on episode nine
now I've started in the past week
you should watch some Firefly if you
haven't watched Firefly I'm [__] like
vlogging it loving it it's so good
talking about Miranda backer in a little
bit I mean
the strike unless the strike ends
tomorrow but because it's only for 14
episodes but it is
perfect I've I've worked I've already
watched it all once this year and I
started the game yesterday
[Music]
and you know I mean I when I got the DVD
set I was actually able to watch it in
order
because when we first showed on Fox it
was like all disjointed out of order on
different night every single week it
seemed like and then they just seemed
like they stopped advertising it all
together
yeah that's a popcorn pie just made fun
he didn't watch Firefly that was the
problem nobody did we all fell in love
with it when the DVD box set came out
Western [__] you know what is this
stuff you know and you know in popcorn
is just exactly right Western space I
mean it's like aliens versus what was
the other thing aliens yes Cowboys
versus Aliens is like really yes now
it's great
this looks stupid but then I caught
um the one where they steal the Lazarus
I caught that episode on Sci-fi channel
one day just by accident and I'm just
like this looks really interesting I'm
intrigued and then I happened to walk
past HMV and I was just like there was
just a big pile of the box sets like 20
quid so I was like I'm gonna give that a
go and then literally 14 hours later I'm
there on my second go round
oh my God and then they I think they
announced the movie and I was just like
this is the craziest day ever
he said he came
popcorn uh you said you come to respect
westerns over time what did you think
about Dances with Wolves oh good
question
it's really long I mean that's like Lord
of the Rings long oh oh like two some
hours you know if you get the extended
edition
Yellowstone as like the prequels dances
when it can get a little bit
it's okay it's okay when Dances with
Wolves first came out as one of the very
first movies to actually show in kind of
somewhat realistic fashion the plight of
the Native Americans the indigenous
people and no one had ever seen that
before really here in America and it was
just like holy [__] yeah you know and
now
um
I'm unsure if the TV show Reservoir Dogs
has helped or hurt
because I swear to God I guiltily love
Reservoir Dogs I can't recommend it to
anybody
reservation dogs
I've been meaning to watch it what in
the hell I mean I love it but it's just
like it's like h r pup and stuff I mean
to me the characters oh just
I love it but
I hope
no yes
for the final term before we go around
again and you complicate these things
[Music]
like seven other shows coming mine
that's the more complicating thing I've
just got 20. well I'm gonna have a whip
through because there's been some
brilliant options in the chat as well
but uh my last one was Farscape I have
to admit again I haven't seen it since
it came out all those years ago
um I love Ben Browder and I love Claudia
Black
um um I love the guy that plays Scorpius
I just thought his character was amazing
um
puppets and stuff and physical
um you know makeup and things I just
thought it was just a brilliant series I
liked Andromeda but Farscape was way
better and I recently watched the first
episode it's actually on YouTube you can
watch it from beginning to end on
YouTube but completely for free
um and I watched the first episode and I
had forgotten how damn good that
introduction episode was it's very much
book Rogers I'm not gonna lie yeah
go in somebody watched book Rogers and
liked it and wanted to throw some
puppets in
um but it's just it's just phenomenal I
mean if you love conceptual sort of
slightly out there sci-fi yeah
it's just amazing and then watch the
peacekeepers wars it's just incredible
they did Five Seasons Four Seasons Four
Seasons in the Peacekeeper Wars if you
like sci-fi and you haven't watched far
skip or something wrong you've got to
watch it
I have Farscape on my hard drive ready
to watch there you go there you go you
are ready I'm Switzerland
so let's go and then complicated then
before we um hey radio TV history how
you doing
um fire Cape is completely free on
YouTube that's insane
the first episode is anyway I don't know
if the rest are but I just checked it's
all four seasons
[Music]
all four seasons are on YouTube yeah
some consumer advice you can go watch it
for free people on YouTube
fantastic Survival Guide just the
epitome of course
just for that because we can all watch
it right go on there because before we
we pick two out of this list how is this
legal
it's probably supported by ads or
something
yeah it does have a lot of uh TV shows
it's ad supported that is legal to
stream
[Music]
I'm not going to complain I have YouTube
premium
exactly
anymore and before we decide uh Freaks
and Geeks just because we I started
thinking about one season early shows in
the 2000s and got canceled way too early
Pushing Daisies but anyway I'm gonna
stop I'm gonna just start naming things
I hated Pushing Daisies
my fault for the company if I didn't say
it was Dexter
I think I would actually put that above
Heroes
There's No in fact I would Dexter is
better than Heroes
okay well I can take it okay so we're
taking out Heroes we're throwing in
Dexter instead okay
I can I'm okay with that that's fine
[Music]
um
Dexter New Blood the new series they did
recently
I really enjoyed it I didn't like the
ending but I didn't like the ending of
Dexter either so
I'm gonna just ends so bad
foreign
season eight well a lot of season
Eight's not that bad and then you get to
the end and it's just well see you next
time the finale isn't it the finale is
awful yeah you just find you find out
he's a lumberjack he's like
um
here we go
I work online yeah
um and then the only the song that I
love that from like that always makes me
think about is um Robin Hood prince of
um
Robin Hood what is it in tight then
attack where men we're Mighty Men Women
looking for fights fights I I totally
forgot about Danny in the middle of the
movie is like the Wikipedia I think of
yeah TV shows
brilliant right so we've got Warehouse
13 which I think we can knock off from
we because even though it was brilliant
did you guys ever watch it
one season
yeah it was good but we can lock that
out so we've got better call style we
got Farscape we've got Supernatural or
Firefly
do we knock out Firefly just because
we're going to watch it anyway and it
only takes actually 10 hours to watch
it's understandable it's not it's not
binge worthy in the sense that you want
to you're knock it out in no time well
you can you can smash them out in a day
if you really want it it's not your
Survival Guide yeah yeah so we'll knock
that out
um Better Call Saul
is on there for me fast gay or
Supernatural I I mean I'm putting it
start I'm just Supernatural because I
didn't watch it all Supernatural you've
got a lot more to watch yeah out of
everything 10 seasons
I think it was 15. 15 Seasons okay
I just can't do I'm sorry off
of all the things that was on that's
coming on off of CW uh Supernatural is
the only thing I've seen from beginning
to end
like like the flag you know the arrow I
just kind of got uh after a few seasons
it was like the same old same old kind
of remixed uh I think it survived Arrow
more than anything else other than uh
Supernatural just kept surviving you
I've got cheat how about if we cheat
slightly because it's our show we do
we're like if we throw in Breaking Bad
and Better Call Saul together
because you've got to watch one to watch
the other it's one continuous IP let's
just call it that
Lions in
um so now you have to toss El Camino in
there too on Supernatural no we don't
yes El Camino is is El green is good I
don't ruin it
Rooney
oh no that's a movie though we're
talking about TV series yes
Breaking Bad is the present practical
soul is the past El Camino is the Future
Okay well it's a movie though so right
we have a top ten guys we have a top ten
okay all right Breaking Bad and Better
Call Saul through through X-Files avatar
The Last Airbender Harris
Dexter Dark Shadows 1200 episodes of it
1230 young man thank you
um Sons of Anarchy Homeland Farscape and
Supernatural is our top 10 list of [__]
binsworthy TV that I now have to watch
you almost said [__] worthy
well one of these two shows are a [__]
worthy so no they're binge-worthy which
is awesome
um we did it
Survival Guide down one more and now we
are never We're Not Gonna stream again
until we've all watched 1230 episodes so
see you in 10 years yeah I need a
knurling
kill me kill me
right cool right so we're gonna move on
to a couple of other things I do want to
talk a little bit about AI in movies
because I've just seen the new
um uh a Mission Impossible film
um I know there you go I don't want to
do any spoilers for it but it's about Ai
and AIS in the news at the moment but
stormy you wanted to say something about
the strike before so I've been reading
yeah I've been reading about a lot of
the mechanics of the strike you know I'm
very supportive of the actors and and
the writers and so forth but there's one
there's one industry in the film
business
that is
so crucial I mean there's other you know
like the
um the direct the the directors have a
guild the lighting guys have a guild the
um
even the prop Masters you know the
editors they all have guilds there's one
group that does not and that's the CGI
guys
I have fun though they do not have one
and I've found there's this user on
Tumblr and yes I'm still on Tumblr yeah
uh and it's a from student of ethereum
they write CGI animators should unionize
next normally their jobs will be too
precarious to strikes and Studios would
replace them without a second thought
but if it's part of a larger general
strike they might finally have
meaningful power to better their working
conditions if CGI animators unionized it
would kill the MCU straight up the
entire business model is built on
exploiting CGI animators I don't care if
you're a fan of Marvel you shouldn't be
but that is also irrelevant either way
so in real and I was I was really almost
really upset that I I thought they were
unionized but they're not
and how many how many screen hours of
everything that's in the MCU has been
because of those guys
and you can see that they're being
massively overworked because that's one
of the reasons why
you know that there's
one of the big arguments against Marvel
in the last few years is these guys are
overworked and it's their work is
suffering yeah um but this is why I did
the video yesterday talking about how do
you how do we support the guild all
these different writers and I don't want
to give money to The Writers Guild all
the Actors Guild because I actually
think this is a bigger problem that the
Studios have shut down a lot of these
people that do the lighting do the
sandwich trucks do all these things
there are short-term contracts as soon
as the studio shut down they're just
gone thank you very much goodbye and
they're out they're out in their ear and
they've got no work so Sidetrack is
going to be supporting the entertainment
Community Fund
um which is the if you go check the
video I did yesterday early morning
there's a link to it in there
um we give
um a small amount of our 10 of our
income every month goes to charity I
choose it for on each month while the
strikes are going on we're going to be
given to that
so um they give money to you can
basically anybody that works in the
entertainment industry can request
support in their emergency fund
um if you're you know literally can't
feed your kids you can't you're not
going to miss rent you're going to do
these sorts of things and it's anybody
in the entertainment industry
um this fund has been going since 1882
or something
um it used to be called the actors fund
but they wanted to spread it and you
know and help anybody in their same
industry they have things like
um they help people find housing and
stuff like that it's a proper it's
really a proactive organization to
really support the people in the
entertainment industry so we're going to
be supporting them while thing goes on
and I will ask anybody else that that
supports Sidetrack to do the same
all right there's a link in that I think
it's
um
entertainmentfund.org I think is the
website yeah entertainmentcommunity.org
is the um
yeah
the I think if there's anything that
the studio should have learned from uh
covid
is that if you take away someone's uh
ability to
uh provide for themselves
go someplace else
you know so there's also I've heard a
little bit of uh ramblings about brain
drain on Hollywood
you know a lot of these people like uh
these craft these craft service people
they'll just you know have they'll just
change their business model a little bit
and just become a food truck tooling
around Hollywood or whatever
you know and because a lot of people
that didn't they did not go back to
their jobs after uh covid because their
jobs kind of sucked they kind of got
used to not being abused by the customer
base and so the thing also I believe
that the studios are risking is a pretty
hideous Talent brain drain
in all sectors you know and I'd like to
hear Harris's comments about this is
specifically you know uh B and C list
actors and and uh uh extras
I mean just moving on to something else
you know some of the performance maybe
like stand up or whatever but what do
you think
uh
I I plead the fifth I'm part of it but I
I've seen a lot of people switch up
careers or at least what they thought
their career would look like
um people that have been doing extra
background work for 15 20 years that it
just you know never really truly plan on
joining the union or anything like that
just it's decent cash and that's what
they were doing and during covid
everything changed a lot of course
because you know you have to take tests
before you go on set which
the only good part about all that was
that you got paid like 90 bucks every
time you got a Cova test so that that
was decent uh
but yeah people got tired of that and
they they completely changed the way
they thought about a lot of things
currently we're seeing a lot of people
that are out of work at the moment that
would be working on these sets and
things going to like reality shows and
things like that just because that's
that's the only paying job at the moment
that's the only thing that's like
workable uh we're it's a little small
independent film so we're not associated
with anything and we're not breaking any
rules or anything but we we're finishing
filming that little horror movie uh this
coming month and we we almost lost our
Director of Photography because he got a
three-month job on a reality show that
he never expected to do I don't think
he's ever done reality before but
because of everything going on he
couldn't say no so it's kind of
it's a course corrected it in a way you
know yeah
but can you imagine how many movies or
TV shows have you that you that we've
talked about in the last year didn't
have any CGI effects
Next To None the the only thing I can
think of is
Oppenheimer
that's it I know they use the actual
explosion didn't they for the um the
real footage that well he said there's
no CGI there's a little bit of animation
and things like that but it's not it's
you you can't tell everything looks
completely real and in camera and of
course that's always his goal which is
why it's the only one I can think of
like that I legitimately can't name
another thing that doesn't use it
hmm
and and the problem is that I mean I was
watching something about I like say I
wanted to mention that I'd watch the
mission impossible today
um there's a lot of CJ in that obviously
but there's a lot of physical
um stunts and things in it as well and
they and he said they purposely said
when we can't when we can do without CGI
we're gonna do without CGI even stuff
for like putting the masks on and stuff
it says a lot of it was physically done
you know they were switching out the
actors and clever camera angles and
stuff yeah so normally we would just
have done CGI but
they just went into it consciously with
a if we don't have to let's not because
it's being overused it's just massively
been overused in cinema and I love that
it just allows you to put things in
frame that like
you usually you would have to hide on a
camera trick or something like that but
that camera trick works so well because
the eye still sees it you know it
doesn't lose that um uh whatever term I
can think of yeah yeah yeah it's still
it's in camera it's it's it's real and
you can visibly tell that versus
there's some there's something uncanny
about CGI and it can be amazing
but if there's a
there's like a bing of any kind like
that's how you typically tell I think I
think Nature's CGI we've almost
perfected in a lot of ways but
you just put something moving too fast
and it's supposed to move with muscles
and stuff like that you can make it look
great
but it's time and money which we were
just talking about a little bit ago they
don't have as much anymore
if we if they unionize the CGI though
will it just go abroad
yeah very quickly very quickly
abroad have you ever read the credits I
mean it's all in India Chinese or South
Korean animators yeah
Germany is the big one at the moment
Germany I've got a massive CGI industry
and I'll tell you I have heard and this
is firmly in the rumor category but I
actually had a guy come to me that did
some work for certain CGI company in
Germany and he said they've been
approached about doing a big project for
MGM and from April till September 2024
doing a lot of the rendering work and he
says he doesn't know if that's Stargate
but it's a Stargate or RoboCop
um and they've been approached and and
written initial contracts apparently
according to him
um I can't I can't confirm whether that
is true or not because I don't I don't
know the source particularly it's just
somebody that like got in touch with
never bothered checking up on it but
because I wouldn't even know where to
start checking if whether that's true or
not but even he said he wasn't sure what
it was but
it's
it's it would seem though that if if
that is true that they're looking for a
gym company to do it and it was like you
said that it's not the first time
Hollywood
you can do that abroad it's very easily
nowadays
um it doesn't need to all be done in
Hollywood and it won't be and this is
what the strike is it really is
important
and there is a risk to the strikers in
Hollywood because the studios don't care
so much they're okay with it getting
even the filming can be done in abroad
to a decent standard map
they don't need Hollywood like they used
to
and that's the risk I think I think that
was one of uh George Lucas's uh
things is um I remember one time he said
I actually heard him say this is uh
actually he's on video he said um
I like programmers more than I do actors
uh and then he was just he was about a
strike and it's one of the reasons why
he did
um
he was uh shooting a lot of uh Phantom
Menace overseas was to avoid
uh the guilts I mean I don't think I
think he left the Director's Guild
didn't he
I don't know if he left it but he did
not like playing in their in their house
he didn't like playing anybody well
that's the whole point in Skywalker
Ranch is like he's like we're getting
the hell out of Hollywood and we're
going a little North you know which I do
not blame him
no there's a reason why Canada's got
such a strong
um industry as well in is that they can
avoid certain aspects of the guilds but
it's still
feels American sort of thing the
Hollywood audience and the American
audience will still accept it yeah
but Stargate the epitome of that yeah
but it's just going further and further
beyond that now so yeah but I agree with
you this there's a real danger
um
uh they're talking about um Harry um
talk about CGI in and we've talked about
this a couple of weeks ago ctie in the
flash is absolutely awful in places
it's it's it's it's
you know really bad
um and sci-fi that I enjoyed the The
Flash but it disaster I didn't mind
instrumental I minded the flying weird
babies
flying weird baby was just strange
so right I've just seen the new Mission
Impossible movie the plot
um is about an AI That's I think that's
out there I'm not spoiling anything for
anybody it's not the thing I do have a
theory that after dead reckoning part
two the sequel movie is called The
Terminator
I actually think the Mission Impossible
movies are prequels
and which nobody knew but they're
prequels
it's the big one
but um I just I just thought about you
guys because I know Harris you've seen
it stormy have you seen the mission
impossible yet no I have not when you do
one thing but it is AI
I mean it's very popular movies right
now but it has been for probably 30
years
one of the best movies that you think
you've seen the way where we've seen AI
an enemy proper AI artificial
intelligence not the AI that people keep
talking about at the moment which isn't
AI
it's
pretending it's a ghost of AI it's not
really AI but anyway
um
what are the best movies do you think
with with AI and one of the ones that
worked and one of the ones that just
didn't A New Hope
C-3PO has the internet already say C3PO
c3p everyone so they're all scared of AI
and I understand it but we're so
predetermined to just think Skynet
Skynet Skynet and like Terminator [__]
C-3PO is a completely viable option for
AI and I'm hoping we get r2d2s and see
the reviews that's what I'm saying C3PO
first time Android on film you know with
anxiety issues
I like R2D2 he's got such a foul mouth
there to beep out every word that man
has to say that's right
I mean he is just he's just like I think
that's um it's a it's an Android from
Glasgow just swears constantly
and anybody since we've been Scotland
you know what I'm talking about
um him or Chopper have you ever watched
Star Wars Rebels Chopper is the only
other kind of R2 type unit that
literally he cusses in the show and it's
Dave filoni voicing him and they have to
like
they they change the speed of how he
says it so it sounds like a Droid and he
just cusses like a [__] it's
hilarious it's so bad excuse my French
but it's great it's so good I love it
yeah
um I I for me the first CGI oh sorry AI
movie I remember was war games
and um and that was a you know the world
is saved by tic-tac-toe you can't argue
with that
um the the wall should be in Saved by
tic-tac-toe every single time
um but if you haven't seen it basically
the the computer is now in control of
nuclear weapons thinks they can win a
nuclear conflict and Matthew Broderick
has to teach him that certain games just
can't be won there is no winner and he
uses tic-tac-toe which we all know if
you get the three corners you can win
tic-tac-toe every single time or it
becomes a draw every single time
um so I don't think they've ever
actually done better than that I know I
know Terminator is basically the sequel
to war game so what it goes is Mission
Impossibles war games
Terminator movies and those those are
those that's they all exist in the same
universe is my theory
um I like that Gannon
if you like what the headcanon that's
your own headcanon but I like it I
subscribe to it now
we got Theory again I think it's a work
in theory I'm just trying to think of
any of the films though that have had
like proper decent AI in it that's
worked 2001
yeah 2001. it really worked
yeah and it was genuinely like that
scared the crap out of a load of songs
they're all going that's that's
realistic that could actually happen oh
[__]
um actually I think any of this RoboCop
I quite like the way how they they sort
of worked that in that he settled those
rules up that were counter-intuitive
what's the movie what actually I set up
like a core principles for the program
but it's I can think about Terminator
they have core principles so they're
computer decides oh no Matrix
it has to protect the planet and decides
that are the only way to protect the
planet is by killing all the humans
basically
and that's like logical that makes sense
I'm like yeah
get rid of us that's all fine
oh oh oh I completely how I just had to
Google movies with AI just to think
about it real quick uh oh okay I
immediately brain farted I gotta look at
it real quick oh there we go I'm back to
my O's ex machina ex machina I watched
ex machina uh three days ago
first time or just like a rewatch second
okay okay it's okay
so good it is you know and so you know
there's a guy at work that is doing a um
he's doing a a paper for college on ex
machina and he really went down the
rabbit hole with this thing and so we
you know we we frequently talk about
this film this last week
one thing that occurred to me in this
last viewing was the dress that she
wears on the way out of the house it's
almost like a wedding dress
kind of yeah
you know and just it was it's just very
well done very well done yeah
kind of the movie that did like Ai and
sort of Androids and stuff quite well
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh uh that makes me think of like chappy
Chappy's kind of up there but it's happy
yeah
I look chappy
yeah I Robot yeah the one thing I have
to think about with them in the the
movie today though that dead reckoning
is this did the um
I'm sure it'll explain it more in the
second film but the
we don't quite know what the motivations
of the AI and they can basically get
into any computer system they're
listening at one point they go in leave
fingerprints and then go out just place
a warning I can get into everything
so it is they call it the entity don't
they but it is unusual like that it goes
in and affects all these systems and
doesn't actually do anything so I'm
really looking forward to the second
part
just really quickly though what did you
actually think of the movie
Paris
spoilers because people haven't seen the
info well uh I I will spoil one thing
immediately is that there's more running
than typical
which I loved every time he runs I just
starts smiling like I think there's
twice as much running as he's ever done
in any other movie and I'm completely
fine with it it's it's so much fun uh
it's almost you know how in the flash
she kind of like gets ready how to do
that little thing or whatever I almost
feel like Ethan Hunt's just like
preparing to do that and then just run
straight Tom Cruise runs I like the bit
in the airport where you see him through
the window at the top and I was like
that's just a poke fun the fact that Tom
Cruise runs all the time you can see it
still you could tell it's Tom Cruise run
and it works so well too at the same
time it's so good I love that that seems
great uh but but I I really did enjoy
the movie I thought it was really good I
think it kind of hurt Itself by calling
it a part one it is a part one I think
it fits as its own Standalone movie just
fine but you can it it you can kind of
feel it I think it's still its own movie
just fine but you can feel that it is
it needs continuing I guess uh I did
find it interesting they talked about
the the five minutes I think of the
submarine was not gonna be in this movie
it was going to be in part two and the
studio said hey you have to put that in
there so I guess Tom Cruise doesn't
always get his way but
I think it made sense and it set the
whole thing up honestly for this movie
some of the fight scenes I'm genuinely
on the edge of my seat and I'm just like
I cannot the fight scene on the little
Bridge oh my god oh great
the train sequence
yep all of it went on a bit but but yeah
I thought it was good honestly I can say
about this film nothing bad there's no
it's the first film I've seen in ages
where I come out and go in that was the
perfect cinematic movie
um that there's nothing wrong with it I
have no complaints it's just a good
popcorn movie it's nearly three hours
long it doesn't feel like it no so the
acting's great the writing is great
there's a couple of little twists there
that you aren't expecting
um there's the whole bit with is the
Gabriel thing though that they I thought
they could have set up a bit more but I
wonder if maybe we're going to get a bit
more in a second
um because it's a bit vague on what's
going on there
um
no complaints go watch it please go
watch at the cinema as well because
honestly
it's brilliant
it is just so fun it's one of those
movies where you're legitimately having
fun just sitting there and watching it
right that's so good perfect Cinema
movie perfect that train sequence was
supposed to be 90 minutes long
originally
there's a 90-minute cut of it somewhere
but I mean the thing is as well it's it
is a perfect Cinema and this is if we
lose our Cinemas which which I think is
a genuine threat I think we could the
big Cinema chains are struggling at the
moment and if we boycott them to you
know support the actual strike I think
that's a massive mistake don't do it
um because it's not you're not just
certain Studios you're hurting the
entire industry and these are the people
that entertain us you know like
give them a Break
um but
um that's the that's the sort of movie
that we're gonna lose if we if we if we
could you're not gonna get you'd have to
have like 100 inch TV screen at home to
enjoy that in the same way as you
enjoyed the cinema and there's just no
way yeah
watch movies
one of the largest Industries on the
face of this planet we like to joke
about it and it is joke worthy but it is
one of the largest Industries on the
face of the planet and it's coming to a
bit of a standstill in the largest heart
of it at the moment which is interesting
all right so yeah there's struggling
they're struggling all right then that's
all I wanted to talk about guys have you
got anything else oh what have you guys
been watching this week anything good
I'm still I am up to season six of
Stargate sg1 uh I'm on my super
super focused uh binge
of all the Stargates and so um on season
six hopefully I'll get close to done
maybe by I'm sorry eight one or sg1 uh
my middle of next week or maybe this
time this week I don't know I still a
lot but
I'm gonna try I'm gonna try yeah
I'm gonna I'm gonna have to binge
Atlantis I've realized because I've been
thinking about it and talking about it
quite a lot and I can't remember
big chunks of Atlantis and I'm gonna
because it's been a while I've watched
sg1 It's relatively regular over the
last few years because it was on sky so
I've been watching it you know as and
when unless I've watched it all again
I've watched seeds and Stargate Universe
because I basically said it was boring
and somebody had to go with me so I'm
like I'm gonna watch it again then and
it is it's still boring first season's
Board second season was getting better
um but I but I haven't watched Atlantis
in years and I'm gonna have to sit and
watch it
so that's that's my next binge Atlantis
it is great
um I just said brain for things um I I
have seen yeah uh The Forbidden project
and yeah and Colossus I have seen them
both not for years though so don't ask
me anything about it
um
but yeah I can't wait I the only thing
I've been watching this year after this
I've just finished watching The Newsroom
which is written by um Aaron Sorkin
which is if anybody just wants to watch
it if you're if you're a trump supporter
for the love of God don't watch it it'll
just make you angry but um if you're not
a trump supporter watch it it's really
thought provoking it's absolutely
brilliant I thought it got canceled
because it wasn't popular but it
actually got canceled because Aaron
stalking got so sick to death of putting
so much work into just 10 episodes he
just gave up he said I'm not doing
anymore it's too much hard work
um but but yeah it's absolutely
fantastic series go and give it a try
Aaron storage a little bit yeah it's
brilliant he's a brilliant writer proper
Democrat but yeah Stormy viewers nothing
you want to throw in Before We Say
Goodbye well I had all these other
choices if it really goes on for a long
time
so on Pluto there's always a space 1999
and there's classic Doctor Who and of
course original OG uh Twilight Zone
uh on Hulu something that I was wanting
to talk about was Sleepy Hollow very
kind of times
guy that played that is just I thought
he was great at the end was crap but the
first season like yeah it was really
really good yeah on Prime you've got Mr
Robot and of course rings of power you
should watch a lot Disney plus if you're
a Disney Plus or Agent Carter which I
think is one of the best Marvel TV shows
just it was in the new Mission
Impossible movie and she's fat excellent
yeah oh she can act as well
and uh Cosmos little educational show
possible worlds and once upon a time
that goes on for a season or two
across the same
it's kind of steady it's kind of sad I
mean you know it's it's broadcast fair
but it the acting was really good acting
was really good that's the Disney one
right with like okay okay
grim
that was a good show Grimm show just
never got canceled again but I tried to
watch it I didn't particularly like it
but I need to push through
I it just it's some people it's just not
their thing something
on Max uh there's Rome
two seasons of that very good
I think it's two seasons a carnival
yeah it's very very good and about four
seasons is The Last Ship
there it's a it's about a uh there's
this uh Navy vessel near the Antarctic
uh collecting
and apocalypse happens when they were in
radio silence for a month the captain is
that guy I think he was in
um Gray's Anatomy or something wasn't he
yes it was yes he was
I like that guy who's like a black tree
was and how many seasons and I watched
the first season but then I sort of I
didn't bother when this happened I think
it's four-ish seasons that was a good
show I enjoyed that yeah
uh Netflix Black Mirror and the Sandman
my wife come to me and said she's bought
my son the comic the first volume of the
comic um the graphic novels to the
salmon this is a Netflix series did you
know and I'm like babe we watched it we
sat together and we watched it remember
the first he was a naked guy and a big
thing and she's like oh yeah I remember
oh
because when I met the first couple it
was I didn't like the first couple
episodes I think you know this is hard
work and but then by the end of it I was
just like
it's yeah
that was a slow burn blast is Apple Plus
you must see c s e e Jason Momoa
excellent Foundation excellent Silo is
excellent in For All Mankind and I think
one thing I want to say about apple plus
is they don't have a lot of shows but
what they do have is all really high
quality stuff they
the next Studio that goes that gets into
real trouble and goes up for sale and I
think it might be Paramount
um Apple will buy
oh my god
um they got outbid they've got like what
almost 100 billion in cash
yeah I mean I mean you know there's
there they got they got profits they got
profits I don't know why they under bid
for MGM they only bid like three and a
half billion or something and um Amazon
came in and went eight
and and they must have just gone what
why are you preparing to eat and they
said they didn't bid again but I mean
Amazon could have sorry Apple could have
just gone from 10. I paid it immediately
um but we'd probably have something on
our screens already too
well because Amazon then have had some
massive cash flow problems
and that's that I have I did speak to
somebody recently they were saying one
of the reasons why they've not announced
anything major from MGM is because
they've got some cash flow problems and
I have to move things around and that
there's a lot of business reasons why
they've not announced anything
to be an issue with MGM as much as I
love the company
yeah well they've MGM is a company
doesn't really exist anymore
that's true apart from the side of a
building
so
that's that's the main reason why this
is all taken so long Amazon has just
been slowly dismantling the company
absorbing what they want to and think
and that that is the the main reason why
we still haven't started getting answers
RoboCop announcer but they haven't
actually announced anything major no
major project from MGM has been
announced since Amazon took it over
nearly a year ago
nearly been a year
has Legally Blonde three officially been
announced or no because that's like the
only thing that I would think like might
be the official announcement illegally
born three was actually in um
pre-production
before the sale went through and it got
paused because of the sale so that was
the one thing that really should have
been done and even that's not right but
it was in pre-production
and jeeper wants to do too they just but
they paused everything
so um basically if it wasn't in
production come August last year they've
they've paused almost everything that
that's not major anyway and a few other
things I feel obviously MGM Plus have
been doing a few things here and I
believe the kid and stuff like that but
nothing yeah
um what do you think about everything
that they've got that they wanted that
we've been talking about Stargate
RoboCop
for Legally Blond three obviously is the
most important of those three but you
know nothing's been announced and it's
and but it's not it's because they had
to restructure MGM and then the strikes
happened so and they knew the strikes
were coming so they prioritized other
things
if this show I'm getting ready to talk
about is
because of the strikes I don't think it
is
but
it's the most insane reality show I have
ever seen
stars on Mars
have you guys heard of this no uh
it's got William Shatner as the host
all right so just I I I I I
don't know
if it's not something Mars I've got a
problem with it it's stars on Mars
I I don't want my um
negative feelings about this to spawn
off on everybody else but just go see it
watch it on your own form your own
conclusions
but you know it's got like a lance
Armstrongs in it and it's just as
yeah it's just stars on Mars and they
fake these
these emergencies in the habitat they
run out of water run out of air
dude it's just I really hope with the
writer strike and everything that this
is not where we're going in terms of
Television oh it is for the time being
bars I mean I
they're Amazing Race is one thing right
but this is a whole different lower
guttural
just watch it and see what you think I
may be wrong stars on Mars so where the
[__] that's the title
I'm gonna keep up with you before we go
one last little question so um I know
Harrison might aren't big trekkies but
me and stormy are so last night it was
announced that we're going from getting
rid of Star Trek the musical
um it's a Subspace Rhapsody
um 10 original songs including one a new
version of Bohemian Rhapsody and put on
based on strange new worlds stormy what
is your first thought about that
a
lot of anger
I mean my question is I I would hope
somehow to get Tim Curry to be in it you
know like a backup background Voice or
something you know it's maybe a tap
dance it's just
I really thought your report when I saw
that you mentioned it
it's like that can't be true but then
you look at all the other shows that's
done it quite successfully I think Buffy
did it twice it's not successful
huh the boys Managed IT fairly
successfully always been successful
that's true the flash did it and it was
awful and I guess from by successful I
mean that they did a musical show and it
didn't cancel the show so but that's the
metric I'm using for it was successful
they didn't cancel yeah
but I I
as long as Tim Curry's in it I'm good
really not well
he's still acting though I mean he could
do the voice over or something he could
do the narration
he's still working my thoughts are in
the video I did earlier but basically I
I spent a bit of time my first thought
was it's a joke
and I'm just thinking well you've only
got 10 episodes why are we wasting one
of them with a musical I just you know
if it was 22 Episodes and we were on
like the fifth season and they thought
let's do a musical I'd be like okay
that's a fun little filler episode why
not but when you've only got 10 and it's
the second season I'm like have you not
really got any other better ideas than a
musical
yeah that's not good because you want
that musical like I keep going back to
the boys but the boys fit that musical
episode in and it worked within the
narrative and it pushed the show forward
at the same time where I I have of
course I haven't seen Star Trek or
strange new worlds or any of that I just
can't imagine that episode pushing the
narrative forward whatever it is I want
to see dancing Klingons
dancing Klingons
sugar dancing Klingons that's what I'm
doing that's the last nail going in yeah
oh we kind of got that in Discovery once
or twice thing and this the klingon's
got sexy and it was painful
was it as sexy as your voice yesterday
on the live stream Klingons on the stop
and yeah it was it was awesome so
um I just wondered what your idea was
before we say good night to everybody
but dear
Jesus God in heaven
um I I just okay um the guy I uh Sean
Ferrick is somebody I really do respect
and he's amazed and he's on track
culture he's he's actually just tweeted
literally even saying what can you
please just tell me how this is going to
hurt you
and now can you please show us on the
diagram where the mean Star Trek musical
episode will hurt you or hurt you I am
much excited because people are
not impressed by this I'm too sexy for
my richer too sexy for my red shirt oh
it's gonna hurt
the mean Star Trek episode tips me on my
sonic screwdriver
well that's doing God knows what to his
David Tennant poster when the camera's
off and he just they have a 10 inch back
there what you doing there
you know I said he's come back and he's
all flush look at him he's all flushed
Rosy what you've been doing back there
um
thank you guys so much brilliant
fun chat as always we will continue
next week with something else
can I come in here with a quick stormy
comment it's not it's not going to be a
20-minute conversation but at the
beginning of our stream Lee Wilcox fish
frogs and four cats has been here the
entire time yeah I think we should put a
petition down to go by the animals that
he called us the beginning of the Stream
[Music]
he said I was a fox I will take it he
called Jamie a gopher uh which was
hilarious
it cracked me up uh Matt was like a
badger and stormy was the wise old owl
and I was like oh my God
hey we're the only Predators uh the
three of us it's the only time we're on
top
and it tried to kill me
um
very excitable I don't know
foreign
[Music]
Harris
I think you should be one of those um
what are the meerkats should be a
meerkat
you're trying to push the rodent off on
me now yeah man I don't want to be a
caddy sack
okay yeah maybe
I'm not sure I'm happy about that
um your lovely aliens to me no matter if
I misroding you ah thank you very much
[__] road
yeah
that's a British joke but anyway right
new name gopher and the Gators
I'm not this isn't sticking if I get
called gopher again on this screen I'm
swear to God
I'm ending it the channel will be
deleted the next day and that'll be it
so if you ever call me go for again that
is it right
yeah the only way to call him go first
to do it in super chats
if I would accept that
but anyway no don't don't do it don't
get into the comments uh go from the
Gators that works oh God
Matthew
[Laughter]
oh dude you did make me laugh well done
sir I missed that comment completely
um and then you got to watch the entire
stream because of it because I would
have blocked you so
um
guys thank you so much it's been
entertaining as always
um I should get some sort of leadership
what's a leadership animal
is it
you can lead from the back of the badger
the back of the owl or the back of the
fox you get options
a lion why can't be a lion
you're lying
oh my my Sat Nav keeps going
um and in 300 yards bear left and every
single time it does it I go
every single time I'm on my own in the
car coming
car says a wolf I want to be a wolf this
is the first time I've never had a
Timeout on give me a timeout please
before you go time me out we don't do
timeouts because I don't know how to do
it
um I can I can literally block you or
not block you and that's it because I've
never looked into it
um a bell sheep almost my weight these
have gone did Matt do that
yeah okay
a wolf I want to be a wolf
Gophers can dig their own Graves that
got dark quick
speaking of the one shows
I'm pretty sure when this channel gets
canceled it either because of stormy or
because why is he banned why is he
banned he's not banned he says it says
Lee Wilcox fish frogs Yeah the band
that's what I was asking I thought you
did that not the time I did time out I
didn't do bad
I Unbound him please it literally says
time out I can't do it so one Banner
there is a little timing thing next to
it but
if you're watching that comments have
been removed I hope I hope not bad I'm
sorry Lee undo it
um I'm trying the line leader is a
female yeah but I don't want to be that
leader I want to I want to sit around
and get women bring stuff to me it was
always a javelina you could be
javelina are more they they are the
people think they're closely related to
Hogs and pigs and stuff but they're more
closely related to nutria they're
literally nutria pigs they are
terrible things
Terrible Things yeah that's probably
true as well I don't have any Pride
javelina yeah
[Music]
this channel will definitely one day get
canceled by YouTube because of stormy or
because I'm trying to talk myself out of
something I've said
and that is digging my own grave and
we're going to get banned for it so I
want that right
um we is back as a Granddad who plays
games now
right so someone told me I mean they
told me a good one he needs it the
naughty little boy
we did it accidentally can we try and
get
um fish and chips back if we can please
because I don't have to do it guys thank
you so much we'll be back next week
um we'll probably be live in the week on
Harris's channel so go and join we might
do a joint video on Wednesday we'll be
on both channels but we need
subscribers for Young Harris is that
live
four nights a week doing your live
videos talking about four or five
typically
so I mean we'll jump on and we help out
and we need subscribers subscribe to
subscribers and there's a link in the
description
is going to be a good one we've got a
sag actor that was at San Diego San
Diego Comic-Con so we're gonna be
talking that a little bit and then uh he
he's also a theater owner and a producer
and stuff like that so
we're talking all the good stuff have
you guys seen Sean Aston uh he's
actually one of the negotiators for sag
have you seen his interviews post post
these negotiations
you you should go look at I mean you
know Samwise gamji he's one of the uh
actual negotiators at the table
um and he's very passionate about it
he's very well I'm surprised he wasn't a
lawyer in another life uh try to dig up
some of his interview people that have
that have interviewed people that's
interviewed him
he he he's very moving you know and and
it's just just go I'll just recommend
hunting down his videos wherever they
may be uh concerning the uh the uh the
actor strike
I've been trying to follow and share as
many tweets as I can from the actors and
the actually people out on the line so
I'll keep looking and find some more but
yeah
all right uh right cool guys
I will see you soon we'll say good night
have fun our challenge question oh God
names the pride of lions a pack of
wolves a murder of crows a herd of
cattle I don't know but put it in the
comments and
we'll find it like
what would we be called we are we a
gaggle that was the first word I was
going to use which is bad
or verbal streamers a Google of
streamers we're a gurgle yeah no no I
got it I got it we're a buff of
streamers oh well I mean hell yeah I
mean come on the thing about you know
we're buffering stream uh okay okay
so much we'll be back next week have a
good one and we'll see you next Sunday
bye foreign
[Music]